are you doing my good oh yeah let me
start by saying congrats for real things
um I'm a really big fan of the way you
move your camera directly I like the way
you have your shot set up in the way the
camera moves how much are you figuring
that how much of you storyboarding how
much are you figuring that in the moment
while you're standing there on set
I don't storyboard I rarely do I mean if
I do it's more for the technical
departments do you know what we might
see what we get under what direction the
cameras can be pointed but uh but I do
like to to keep it fresh and keep it you
know I spent aeneas I think and every
day like some of some of the best stuff
comes up on today I'm you know one of my
favorite shows in the movie the opening
shot of the actual movie after the title
credits that you know present this guy
talking to his wife and and it seems
like just a normal evening and then we
learn a bit more about it it's it's one
of the things that we just pay they're
over my DPM myself which I work with on
don't breathe as well with just on the
fly yeah trying to figure it out and we
find an idea and I think that's because
you never know how the place is going to
look in the day so you have to if you
have made any decision too many
decisions before then you login to
yourself down to something that might
not be right what was it about this
project that said I am this is my
project after don't breathe well I think
it had for for a movie that I was gonna
have a bigger canvas right it felt like
was the tone was kind of in the world of
the movies that I've been making this
okay obviously there's an evolution
there and and though he still Raider are
it's a bit it's not as dark as the other
ones but but in at the same time I you
know for me
when I think of something like this it's
all about making us different as I can
for what's be in the past right if
you're looking for the dark bleak Nordic
noir go watch the other movies right
they still there this is something
completely different and that's what I
really hope to give the audience right
so some of their never thought I was
gonna be that and I'm so and I think
that that's a somewhat I enjoyed to do I
never I never liked the audience to
watch the trailer of mine and go like I
exactly what that is always we always
want them to go and go well you know I
thought it's gonna be that um the movie
is definitely fast moving it propels at
a very you know it's fast talked a
little bit about the challenge of having
those character moments and you want to
explore stuff but the modern audience
now so many people need it they want it
to be you know propelling yeah well yeah
that's a big challenge I mean it is huge
and it's it's complex and it changes
every day and that's why Hollywood such
a tricky business in a way like no one
really has knows oh this is how you make
a hit this is how you reach a big
audience because the audience is
constantly changing write what they want
last year is not what they want this
year it's not and what they want now is
not what they're gonna want next year so
so he's really one of the things that
how much character you give them how
much blood you give them it's it's a
fine line and yeah you never really know
and something like this it was
interesting because obviously the
audience it's impossible to take out of
their minds the previous experience they
had with the character so you think so
probably expect a lot more of that very
long scenes of character and explore
exploration and and here you have you
have a plot that is pushing so that's
why I said this is more James Bond then
I got the Christie right if you compare
with the previous stories I'm always
obsessed with the editing with how a
movie comes together in the editing room
because they're the final rewrite how
long was your first cut compared to the
finished film no it was just seven
minutes longer I think so not anything
crazy no no I tend to design because
because I write them I tend to have a
clearer idea of a design of what it's
going to be and in the way I build my
movies it's not easy to swap scenes
around you know let's take this thing
out and that's it usually they build in
a way that there's there's no under ways
to tell that story it's it's just works
in this search and it has certainly
linearity like don't breathe it was one
of the things you couldn't take one
piece out it will fall apart right it
would make no sense so it's a kind of
similar thing here what I'm assuming you
did some test screenings what did you
learn from those test screenings that
may be impacted the finished film it's
interesting with death screenings like
and I never had a bad test coming
movies like I kind of make them for the
audience like really I'm a crowd pleaser
I try to be I try to give the audience
what they really want and from the
design from the original design of food
from the script so usually one would go
and test it it's always a fun screen so
so you're not in that place where you
like that doesn't work you're trying to
fix it too to see how can it be better
but something I did learn that was
interesting that is really that this
concept that the more information you
put the more details you give the
audience to understand what's going on
the slower the film feels the with the
change the length never changed but it
felt for some people were more we
explain this our thing it feel like it
kind of slowed down in this part because
I I try to make the movies a bit cryptic
in a way do not give them enough to say
enough about what's going on but I like
to see you whispered to whoever still
next to you saying like I think that guy
is with that other guy sure and then
goes I wasn't now oh no you were right
he wasn't that sort of thing is
something that keeps you engaged with
the filming it makes you participate it
makes you think harder about what's
going on it makes you squint at the
screen and figure out that way what what
okay got it that when stories are too
literal and tell you everything then you
go like well it's obvious anybody can
tell on that note I will say next to see
you again sir hope it's a huge hit thank
you thank you so much man
you